hey guys in this video i'm going to talk
about faith and importance of kinvara a
red priestess who is one of the high
ranked leaders in the fate of the lord
of light quinoa appeared in fifth
episode called the door of season six
and from only that one scene it was
pretty obvious that kimwire will play a
major role in the upcoming seasons as we
all know kinwar accepted tyrion's
invitation who sent it in order to gain
her assistance in convincing people to
follow daenerys as their protector
rather than a conqueror
after kinvara accepted tyrion's
invitation she met with tyrion lannister
and varys in the great pyramid of marine
quinmara stayed silent while tyrion
greeted her in valyrian whereupon she
said in the common tongue that he does
not need to persuade her into helping
because as quenmar said herself she
believes that daenerys is the one who
was promised using dany's freeing of the
slaves and her dragons as an examples of
her claim
i have to tell you that while we're all
expecting from the show to reveal that
jon is the prince that was promised it
also might be the nearest targaryen as i
have already said in one of my previous
videos also quinmar is not the only one
who said that daenerys is the one who
was promised in the books maester
raymond pointed out that in high
valyrian which is the language which was
used in most versions of the prophecies
the word corresponding to prince is
gender neutral pointing out the fact
that the prophecy is not specific about
the promised person's gender
i'm not saying that daenerys is
definitely the one who was promised but
there are a lot of matches between
daenerys and prophecy matches which some
could while a lot considering as the
proofs depending on how you see it
in fact the prophecy more than fades
daenerys the prophecy says that prince
that was promised aka the one who was
promised would be quote born amid salt
and smoke beneath a bleeding star
unquote
she was born in dragonstone an island in
the narrow sea meaning that we have soul
from the waves hitting the shores of
dragonstone and also she was reborn as a
mother of dragons on carl drogo's
burning funeral bonfire which matches
the part of prophecy which includes a
mid smoke
also very important fact is that in the
morning for the first time the red comet
appeared in the sky which fits the part
which says beneath the bleeding star
for the final confirmation of daenerys
being the one who was promised we have
an additional prophecy from the woods of
which prophesies that the prince that
was promised will be born from the line
of aerys cinderella
as we all know this prophecy also fits
daenerys perfectly since daenerys is a
daughter of aerys and raela targaryen
when samuel tarly told to amazed raymond
rumors about the nearest targaryen and
her dragons eamon became certain that
danny is prophesied leader eamon told to
sam
no one ever looked for a girl it was a
prince that was promised not a princess
and also told to sam that daenerys is
the one born amid salt and smoke the
dragons prove it
in maester raymond's earlier life he
thought ragar was the prince that was
promised as ryagar was born during the
tragedy at summer hall amid smoke of the
burning castle while salt was provided
from the tears of those who cried for
those who had died but at time eamon was
wrong
now that we know that quinmara is not
the only one who puts daenerys and the
one who's promised together let's
continue with kinwara's importance
there's no doubt about kinvara's
importance in the upcoming seasons which
we could realize only considering how
important melisandre's role has been so
far and believe me when i say that
melisandre's powers can't even be
compared to quinvaras
you might think that my statements are
wrong that are not true and i can
understand that but let me explain why
in my opinion kinvara will play a big
role in season 7 especially in season 8.
i'm aware that melisandre has played one
of the biggest roles i mean without her
jon would have been dead which is her
biggest achievement but also with other
stannis would have also still been alive
while melisandre has played a huge role
in previous seasons in my opinion as
i've said in video about mensandra's
fate beside two big encounters that she
will probably have in season seven in my
opinion she will disappear for the most
of season where upon she will reappear
dramatically either near the end of the
upcoming or in the very beginning of the
last eighth season but it's only my
opinion i could be wrong melisandre
might be included in every single
episode but i just don't see it that way
in case i'm wrong in case that
co-producers david and dan decide to
include melisandre in most of episodes
in that case i see melisandre in
winterfell during the almost whole
season hiding behind her true form a
theory which i brought to you in a video
about melisandre's fate so if you find
this theory interesting feel free to
check it out
however as i was saying quinoa is much
more powerful than melisandre quinmar's
title is high priestess of the red
temple of volantis the flame of truth
the light of wisdom and first servant of
the lord of light which says itself how
much powerful quinmara is while
melisandre's only title is a red
priestess of the lord of light
let me quote one her sentence that she
told varys everyone is what they are and
where they are for a reason terrible
things happen for a reason they could
happen to you lord varys when you were a
child if not for your mutilation the
hand of a second raid sorcerer you
wouldn't be here helping the lord chosen
bring his light into the world i've been
wondering what kinwara wanted to imply
on when she said if not for your
mutilation you wouldn't be here helping
the lords chosen quinvara clearly meant
that if not for his mutilation he
wouldn't be helping daenerys right now
but i'm wondering is it because of the
voice and the flames that varys heard
did he gain all power that he has and is
helping daenerys because of words
because the boys told him to
i'm aware that it's hard to find an
accurate answer on this but in this
theory in which the voice came out from
the flames told various to serve him and
to help daenerys certainly is an
interesting theory at least for me while
we know for sure that ferris got his
revenge as we saw a scene in fourth
episode of third season in which we
could see that varys was clearly
torturing that same sorcerer that once
tortured him a scene which explained a
lot in that same scene verse admitted to
tyrion that he heard a voice and that he
still dreams of that night the night
when all of that happened to him
therefore he also admitted that it's not
because of sorcerer or his blade that he
dreams of but because of the voice from
the flames in the books verse doesn't
even know what he heard at night when
verse described the haunting story of
his castration he said that when the
sorcerer threw his parts into the fire
he heard a strange voice speaking a
language he could not understand and
also said that he was drugged and in
pain pointing out that he often told
himself that he must have hallucinated
the voice while this is the case in the
books i don't think it's the same in the
show in the show where said himself that
he still remembers the voice in addition
he said he dreams of it every now and
then which kind of confirms that verse
knows what the voice said and by his
face expression when quinmar asked him
i'm quoting again
you heard the voice call out from the
flames do you remember
should i tell you what the voice said it
was pretty obvious that he knows and
that he exactly understood the words
that came out from the flames but let's
assume that just like in the books first
didn't understand what the voice was
saying on the tv show as well it would
still be obvious that varys who can be
considered as one of the most clever men
in seven kingdoms would learn that
language on which voice was talking
would learn and solve the meaning of
those words since he still knows and
dreams of the voice and words that came
out of it
so yeah it's most likely that verse
knows what the voice said exactly and in
my opinion that same voices risen
affairs being on the place in which she
currently is and the reason of him
helping the nearest targaryens is the
very beginning
let's get back to quinmara let's get
back on statement which confirms my
statement that kinvara is way more
powerful than melisandre while the
meeting was getting between her and
tyrion along with varys to an end
quinmar assured tyrion that she will
summon her best priestess and preachers
to speak about the queen through all of
essos
did you catch and figure out that
particular part of sentence in which she
said i will summon my priestesses that
means that she has higher rank compared
to someone like melisandre as first part
of her title says itself high priestess
of the red temple of volantis which also
supports my statement that quinmar has
more power than other ordinary red
priestesses considering how young
kinwara looks it's most likely that she
is just like melisandre hiding behind
her true form additionally in my opinion
quinoa should be much older since
melisandre is only an ordinary red
priestess while quinmar has a much
higher title in conclusion quinoa will
in my opinion play a huge role in the
upcoming seasons quinmara also has much
more power than mel sandre or any other
red priestess which is kind of certain
statement after all we could call it
arguments that i brought you today
let me know your opinion on all of this
in the comments section down below don't
you think that quinoa's role is yet to
come because it wouldn't kind of make
sense to bring that powerful and
important character in the show without
any further importance don't you think